If you do the three things I tell you to
do the night,
I guarantee you whatever it is you want
to do,
a light you'll be able to do,
you won't be able to accomplish whatever
you want to academically,
financially,
relationally,
whatever.
So three things.
All right,
I'm going to tell you the story and the
story is about,
you guys have probably heard about this
before.
It was a,
it was a young man who,
you know,
he wanted to make a lot of money and so
he went to this guru,
right?
And he told the Google,
you know,
I want to be able to same level you are.
That's what the Guru said.
If you want to be on the same level I'm
on,
I'll meet you tomorrow at the beach at
4:00
AM.
So the young man got there at 4:00
AM the old man grabs his hand and said,
how bad do you want to be successful?
He said,
real bad.
walk on out in the water.
So he walks out into the water,
watch this.
When he walks up to the water that goes
waist deep.
So he said,
come out a little farther.
Walked out,
look for then he had it right around
this area.
Said,
come on out.
A little part that came out a little
farther.
It was right at his mouth.
My man like,
I'm about to go back in here.
This God is mine for the old man said,
I thought you said you wanted to be
successful.
He said,
I do.
walk a little further.
He can drop this head and held him down.
Hold him down.
Mumia getting scratchy.
Just before my man was about to pass
out,
he raised him up.
He said,
I got a question for you.
Somebody answered the question for me.
He said,
when you were underwater,
what did you want to do?
Said I wanted to breathe.
He told the guy,
he said,
when you want to succeed as bad as you
want to breathe,
then you'll be successful.
I don't know how many y'all got asthma
here today,
but if you ever had an asthma attack me
for you.
Short of breath,
sob,
shortness of breath,
wheezing.
The only thing you tried to do is get
some air.
You don't care about no basket ball
game.
You don't care what's on TV.
You don't care about nobody calling you.
You don't care about a party.
The only thing you care about when
you're trying to breathe is to get some
fresh air.
That's it.
And when you get to the point where all
you want to do is be successful,
as bad as you want to breathe,
then you'll be successful.
And I'm here to tell you number one,
that most of you say you want to be
successful,
but you don't want it bad.
You just kind of want it.
You don't want it bad.
And then you want to party.
You don't want it as much as you want to
be cool you,
most of you don't want success as much
as you want to sleep.
You gotta be willing to work off for
three hours of sleep,
two hours.
If you really want to be successful,
some days you will have to stay up three
days in a row because if you go to
sleep,
you might miss the opportunity to be
successful.
That's how bad you got a warning.
50 cent was doing this movie.
I did a little research on 50 and 50
said that when he wasn't doing the
movie,
he was doing the sound track and they
said,
when do you sleep?
50 sleep?
He says,
sleep.
Sleep is for those people who are broke.
I'm asleep and I'm here to tell you
today if you got somebody came off the
other day crying,
I said,
look,
don't cry to give up.
Keep going.
Don't cry to quit you already in pain.
You already hurt.
Get a reward from it.
Don't go to sleep until you succeed.
The most important thing is this.
To be able at any moment to sacrifice
what you are for,
what you will become.
That's the number two thing.
You got to catch that one.
Some of you,
you focused into the phone ring and then
you're like,
I got an answer.
If I don't answer the phone,
I'm going to die.
I'm saying to you today that there is
some of you,
if you give up your cell phone,
you will be successful,
but your cell phone is more important to
you than your success because the time
you spend on your cell phone could be
used for your success,
the time you could be using to be
successful,
you will use it on the sale and the cell
phone is not bringing nothing but a bill
to be able at any moment to sacrifice
what we are for what we could be.
I don't do well in math.
You right.
You ain't never studied.
I'm not good in writing cause you had
never written before,
but I dare you to fail and writing for a
whole year to see if you can get to the
end.
I dare you to fail.
Always want to give up.
I'm dropping.
Why are you dropping?
I'm so grateful that the slaves didn't
drop and quit.
Say,
I'm just going to stop.
I'm a slave.
I'm just going to be a slave.
I'm a quit.
Listen to me.
The slave said,
we will live because one day we will
become and one day our children will be
free.
If the slaves would have just said,
we quit,
we give up,
we would have died in the middle
passage,
but some slaves said,
I don't care what we go through.
We going to survive this 400 years of
slavery.
We to get through this and you can't get
through an 1825 the problem is you ain't
never felt no pain before your soft.
It's a soft generation.
You quit on everything.
I people did not quit.
You quit and you ain't even tried yet.
Last one,
I'm sorry.
Last one.
Listen to me.
Pain is temporary.
It may last for a minute or an hour or a
day or even a year,
but eventually it will subside and
something else will take its place.
If I quit,
however it will last forever.
But I was homeless for two and a half
years and the problem with most of you,
you never felt no pain before y'all
spoiled.
Y'all spoiled.
Some of y'all spoiled,
just bottom line.
Your parents had done everything for
you.
You never had to do nothing for
yourself.
You're spoiled.
Are we gonna keep it real tonight?
Some of you are spoiled brats.
Every time you ever got in trouble,
somebody in your house got you out of,
and some of you have never learned to
grow up.
And so every time something gets hard,
you quit.
You called Momma,
I dare you to take a little pain.
I dare you.
I dare you not to go home.
Somebody said I got him go home.
I feel bad.
Go throw it.
You Ain't going to die at the end of
pain and success,
you're not going to adopt because you
fill in a little bit.
Hey,
you have to give it everything.
You've got.
No more TV,
no more parties,
no more player.
If you will have a 4.0
what you need to be doing is study.
Get off the phone.
I'm sorry,
I'm not available until the end of this
year.
I'm about to get busy.
Nah,
what?
I'm exactly where I wanted to be because
I realize I've got to commit my very
being to this thing.
I gotta I gotta breathe it.
I got it,
eat it,
sleep it,
and until you get there,
you'll never be successful in life.
But once you get there,
I guarantee you the world is yours.